willkommen bei einer neuen sendung von
4cast und heute geht es um die
berufsperspektiven für philosophen ja
ich habe ja echt wie ihr philosophie wie
du weißt gibt es in welche chancen in
einem beruf zu bekommen was kann ich
damit anfangen das ist eine gute frage
philosophie im studium bereitet
eigentlich nicht konkret auf einem
speziellen beruf vor
wir sind als philosophen und philosophin
generalisten wir können alles oder auch
nichts
und diese generelle ausrichtung des
studiums ist erstmal ein problem es gibt
keinen konkreten beruf philosoph dann
würde vielleicht ihr sagen philosophie
zu studieren ist eine berufung wir
machen das weil wir es gern machen
wollen aber es gibt keine konkreten
kompetenzen die jetzt in ganz speziellen
berufen gefordert sind das heißt wir
müssen selbst aktiv werden und uns
selbst ein profil schaffen
ok das heißt aber wenn ich jetzt so
einem arbeitgeber gehen und ein jobsuche
und sage ich bin philosoph habe ich
keine chance das würde ich nicht sagen
aber es kommt eben darauf an den
arbeitgeber dann zu überzeugen mit
bestimmten kompetenzen ja die man sich
erarbeitet hat und da hast du da
konkrete kompetenzen ja also ich meine
was man natürlich generell lernt in
philosophie studium ist sich gut
auszudrücken sich verständlich
auszudrücken wir halten referate im
studium wir schreiben sehr viel wir sind
sehr gut in dem schriftlichen ausdruck
wir können logisch denken mit der fall
jedenfalls das sind gesamt
grundkompetenzen dann haben wir soft
skills wir können vor größeren mengen
reden zum beispiel wenn man referate
halten
aber dazu muss natürlich dann noch was
anderes kommen sich ein eigenes profil
zu erarbeiten das kann man machen indem
man zum beispiel schon während des
studiums praktika macht in verschiedene
bereiche hinein geht die ein später mal
interessieren würden oder indem man zb
noch eine weitere ausbildung macht ein
zusatzstudium beginnt oder aber auch
auslandsaufenthalte macht ok bevor wir
zu den auslandsaufenthalten kommen gibt
es ja beispiele viele meiner
kommilitonen habe ich mitbekommen dass
die mittlerweile anfangen
unternehmen dieses berufsfeld ist
unternehmensberater und es irgendwie aus
zu checken und warum dass das jetzt zum
beispiel ein beliebter weg von
philosophen also spricht so ein guten
punkt an viele meiner studienkollegen
sind am ende
in diesem feld gelandet die haben
unternehmensberatung wirtschaftlichen
genau diagnose nicht will sie jetzt
nicht nennen jeder kennen sie diese
großen unternehmen und erstaunlich viele
meiner kolleginnen und kollegen oder
kommilitoninnen und kommilitonen sind
darin untergekommen in diesen umfeldern
einfach deswegen weil sie eigenständige
denker waren also die haben dem
arbeitgeber signalisiert ich bin nicht
einfach irgendein arbeitnehmer sondern
ich habe eine ganz eigene ansicht der
welt also hat man doch ein
herausstellungsmerkmal ein
alleinstellungsmerkmal in dem sinne dass
man eine grundkompetenz hat zum beispiel
wirtschaft die man sich eben nach dem
philosophie studium aneignen könnte und
dann wäre dieses analytische denken ganz
gut aus weise noch mal so der punkt wo
man sagen okay wir nehmen dich oder
genau darüber
du sprichst wichtigen punkt an das
analytische ding das logische klare
denkt das lehrt man vielleicht in keinem
anderen studiums so gut wie in der
philosophie wir haben logik kurse müssen
hausarbeiten schreiben wir müssen klar
uns ausdrücken und wenn man das schon im
bewerbungsgespräch kommuniziert denke
ich hat man schon einen guten punkt
gemacht natürlich muss man dann bereit
sein sich in neue materie einzuarbeiten
das sollte man also immer auch
kommunizieren ich bin offen ich bin
lernbegierig ich bin sein lebenslanges
lernen und philosophie hört ja auch nie
auf das stimmt ja auch nicht jeder neue
philosoph ist sondern neue sichtweisen
und es stellen sich uns ständig neue
fragen des fragen hörte an der
philosophie nie auf und wenn man das
kommuniziert dass man offen und
eigentlich ja das ist eine andere frage
darüber macht man noch mal eine eigene
single aber das kommt jetzt offen mich
weiterzubilden auf neue
herausforderungen reagieren dann solltet
ihr an jeder arbeitgeber daran
interessiert sind okay und jetzt
bezüglich auslandsstudium beziehungen
oder welche erfahrungen kann man im
ausland machen und
wo liegt der unterschied im ausland zu
den deutschen universitäten auch eine
wichtige frage ich habe vorhin schon
erwähnt man kann sich kann seine
attraktivität für den arbeitsmarkt
steigern wenn man eben während des
philosophie studiums praktika machen
oder eben auch auslandsaufenthalte und
wir haben hier in der lmu zum glück sehr
gute partnerschaften zu
partneruniversitäten kann sich jeder mal
informieren im internet studiengangs
berater fragen gibt auch beauftragte
erasmus und so weiter und so fort es
gibt bestimmte partnerschaften zum
beispiel haben wir eine partnerschaft
mit der university of berkeley
kalifornien
das ist sehr gut dann lohnt sich einfach
mal sich zu erkundigen welche
universität interessiert mich am meisten
und vor allem auch in welches land
mächtig und da kann ich aus meiner
erfahrung sehe die usa empfehlen
nordamerikanischen universitäten sind
häufig sehr sehr wohlhabende
universitäten da muss man auch
studiengebühren bezahlen und zwar nicht
wenig und die werden uns dann erlassen
wenn wir dort aufgrund dieser
partnerschaft studieren und in den usa
sind die universitäten sehr wie ein
campus organisiert also alles ist sehr
eng aufeinander und es entsteht eine
ganz besonders intensive
arbeitsatmosphäre
die ungemein fruchtbar wirkt auf die
eigene arbeit und so eine
auslandserfahrung ist sehr sehr gut
nicht nur für fachliche sondern auch für
die persönliche entwicklung und das
macht sich natürlich auch im lebenslauf
sehr gut von potenziellen arbeitgeber
später war okay ja vielen dank
dann hoffe ich dass jeder hier etwas
mitnehmen konnte für sein zukünftiges
berufsfeld als philosoph oder eben mit
der philosophie und wir sind uns bei der
nächsten folge von 4cast